على الرغم من ان المواقف المعلنه لتبشر
بقرب التواصل الى تسويه مرضيه للطرفين
الروسي والاكراني الا ان نتغير في الموقف
الاوكراني يشير الى امكانيه تجميد الصراع
في اوكرانيا حيث المحاوله ديمرجيلنسكي
لاحتمال عقد محادثات سلام مع روسيا في
تحول عن رفضه السابق للتفاوض مع الرئيس
الروسي اولاد ميركوتي
المسلحه من اراضي اوكرانيا يجب ان تستعيد
اوكرانيا سيطرتها على جميع اجزاء حدودها
مع روسيا سيؤدي هذا الى وقت الحقيقي
الرئيس الاوكراني حتى ايضا المجتمع الدولي
على اجبار الروسي على اجراء محادثات سلام
خمسه شروط للتفاوض مع روسيا استعاده وحده
الاراضي واحترام ميثاق الامم المتحده
والتعويض عن كافه الاضرار التي تسببت فيها
الحرب ومعاقبته جميع مجرمين الحرب وضمن
عدم تكرار ما يحدث شروط اعتبرها وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سرغي لافروف انها غير
واقعيه وذلك خلال تصريحات ادلى بها خلال
قمه مجموعه العشرين
قاطع المفاوضات ويطرح شروط من الواضح انها
غير واقعيه ولا تتناسب مع الوضع على الارض
ذكرتني
مجموعه العشرين حول الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا تصاعدت الضغوط على روسيا لانهاء
الحرب ذات التكاليف الماديه والبشريه
الباهضه